Hey everyone, welcome back to
mCoding with JamesMurphy. That's me!
Today, I'm getting you up to
speed with your ABCs.
Wait, can I say that, oris this
going to get flagged as "for kids"?
No, not the alphabet ABCs of course,
I'm talkingabout Abstract Base Classes.
Specifically, the abstract collections
definedin the Collections abc module.
I'll talk about when and
why you shoulduse them,
including both their typing and
runtime use cases, and their mix-inuse cases.
Then, we'll finish up
with an example
where we use an abstract collection to
implement this "Invertible Dictionary" class.
It's just like a dictionary that
you can use to map keys to values.
But you can also map those values
back to their starting keys.
Let's get started by taking a
quick look at theCollections ABC docs.
The first thing to notice is that
there are quite a few of these ABCs.
Their primary purpose is to serve as
sort of an interface to some of the built-in tools.
So, if you wanted to write
your own version of that tool,
you just need to implement
these methods to conform to that interface.
Some are very simple interfaces, like the
`Iterable`, which just needs to define a __iter__ method.
Others, like the `Sequence` or
`MmutableSequence`, require a few more methods.
So, if I want my type to
be considered a sequence,
I should deine a __getitem__, __len__, __contains__,
__iter__, __reversed__, index and count function.
If you want your type to be considered a
`Sequence`, you do need all these methods.
But these are also ABCs.
You can use themas base classes.
And if you use them
as a base class,
then really you only need
to define things in this middle column.
So, if I define `__getitem__` and `__len__`
and inherit from `Sequence`,
then Python will provide default
implementationsof the things in this right column.
Also, notice that there's a `Sequence`
anda `MutableSequence`.
There's a `Set` and a `MutableSet`,
there's a `Mapping` and a `MutableMapping`.
Remember, these are just interfaces.
So if you annotate something as being a `Mapping`,
that doesn't mean it
also can't be mutable.
This distinction has more to do with
type hintingas a way of telling your callers
thatyou're not going to modify their map,
rather than defining a type that can't bemutated.
Although that's also
a possibility.
Obviously, there are too many
ofthese to fully cover in one video.
So that's why I'm announcing a 15-part
sequence... no, I'm just kidding.
There are just a few that are the
most commonthat you'll actually use.
`Iterable`: stuff you can iterate over.
`Sequence`, and `MutableSequence`
are abstract versions of a list.
Then there is`Set` and `MutableSet` which
is the abstract version of a set.
`Mapping`, and `MutableMapping`
which are the abstact version of a dictionary.
I recommend just coming back to thistable
if you ever need to rememberwhat's part of the interface.
For the restof this video, I'm just going
to focus on `Mapping` and `MutableMapping`.
So, on toour first example
use case: type hinting.
Here's a very simple function
that's meant totake in a dictionary
and just delete the
entry with the smallest key.
If it's empty, we
justreturn. We don't error.
We find the smallest
key and then delete that entry.
Now, I'm notsaying that you
should be typing all of your code all the time.
I think type hinting is an
optional feature of Python, as it should be.
One of the main benefits,
of course, is autocomplete.
Because I haven't type hinted `d`, PyCharm is
giving me basically no good suggestions here.
But if I annotate it as a `Dict` and try again,
now I'm getting a lot more relevant suggestions.
And yes, you can get even better suggestions
if you specify the key type and value type.
But one issue that a lot of people don't thinkabout
is how restrictive this can be for thecaller of the function.
As the author of codelike this, it might be
most convenient to specify an exact type here.
But if this is an internalfunction and
there may be other people calling your function,
putting this type in here actually
becomes a restriction.
Doing an `if` check,
finding the minimum key,
and deleting a key
are not specific to the built-in `dict` type.
If a user has something like a custom dictionarytype,
maybe they're wrapping a dictionary type,
they might still want to use your function,
andyour implementation might still work for them.
But because of
your restrictive typehint,
now their editor
is going to complain
that they're doing something
wrong when, in fact, maybe it's just fine.
In many cases, if you've
hinted something tobe a dictionary
and it's a public-facing API, consider that
a `MutableMapping`might be a more flexible option.
Also, note that our use of
`MutableMapping`helps inform our caller
that we do intend to
mutate their dictionary,
which may not have been
apparent if we had just annotated it as a `dict`.
But type hinting isn't the only
use case for theseabstract collections.
It's possible to check,
and a lot of code does check,
whether something isan instance
or a subclass of one of these ABCs at runtime.
This allows you to react differentlybased
on the structure of the object that you received.
Something that is actually quite
useful in a dynamic language like Python.
Here we're defining a `deep_min`,
whichis just like a `min`,
but it will also traverse any
structures like lists or dictionaries
andgo inside of them
to find the smallest element.
So even if I had this
nested list of numbers,
`deep_min` would still find this
zero and pick that out as the minimum.
If somethingis iterable, then we just recursively find
the deep_min and then take the minimumof those.
But specifically for mappings,
we may not be interested in the keys.
We don't want to find
the minimum key.
So if we do see a mapping, then we
onlyrecurse into the values, not the keys.
And if we get something
not iterable, like a number,
thenthat's our base case
and we just return the value.
It's pretty common for a library
author todo this kind of switching.
And if they do, it would typically be based
on one of the ABCs inthe Collections ABC module.
There's also a lot of Python
internals that use this machinery.
Forinstance, if you're using the
`match` statement from Python 3.10,
then a case like this that
looks like it's using a dictionary
will actually match
against any mapping type.
If you wantyour custom type to pass
these `isinstance` or `issubclass` checks,
then you can, of course,
inherit from `Mapping`.
Or if you don't want to or
can't inherit from `Mapping`,
you could also fakeinherit
from it by using the `register` method.
This will make Python treat this class like it's
a subclass of `Mapping`, even if it's not.
Now, you're basically asking
Python to justtrust you on this one.
So if you do this, then make sure
that you actually implement theinterface.
Otherwise, weird things might fail.
Alright, so how do we
actually make ourown mapping type?
We're going to see by implementing an
"Invertible Dictionary,"which is like a two-way dictionary.
It can go from keys to values, but it
can alsotake values and go back to keys.
Of course, type hints are
completely optional.
But I thinkit actually clears
things up in this case.
So I will go ahead and
put them in.
`KT`and `VT` stand for key
type and value type.
We're going to implement this `InvertibleDict`
by just having two dictionaries
A forward dictionary and
a backward dictionary.
Forwardmaps keys to values,
and backward maps values to keys.
We'll go ahead and use slots because
why not? See my video on slots.
For this example, we want to
actually inherit from "MutableMapping"
because we want to take advantage
of the mix in default implementation methods.
Going back to this one
with the table,
we see that if we define __getitem__,
__setitem__, __delitem__, __iter__ and __len__,
then Python will define all
the rest of these methods for us.
Meaning we don't have to define
any of these standard dictionary functions,
or any of these mutating
dictionary functions.
The abstract base class will provide default
implementations just using the files that we did provide.
So we go back to our implementation
and these are the five we actually need to define.
After we define those five, then we could use
our class just like we use dictionary in most cases.
Everything else is either extra
functionality like inverse function
or typical customization
point like a __repr__
or custom implementation of something
that could have been provided by the ABC.
We will see
more on that later.
Of course, the way we write these
five depends on the structure of our class.
The way I've designed things, our class
just stores the forward and backward dictionaries
which we initialized in
the init function.
Typically, we would just have the
user passin the forward dictionary,
and then we would just
compute the backward one.
Depending onwhat they provide, we
either start with an empty forward and backward
or we start with theforward they
give us and compute the backward.
Or, if they provide this backward parameter,
it's kind of like a secret parameter,then we just use it.
It's kind of a convention inPython
that if you have a keyword-only argument
that starts with an underscore, it's
kind oflike a private implementation detail.
Of course, it doesn't actually
stop anyone from usingit,
but that's the way that
we're going to be using it.
So our own internal functionslike the `inverse` function
might want to provide this backward argument,
but atypical user
shouldn't be providing it.
The specific details of __init__
areactually not that important.
Just keep in mind that `forward` and
`backward`are just plain old dictionaries.
So when someone goes to look
upa key, how do they do it?
Well, looking up a key is pretty simple.
We just lookit up using the forward dictionary.
Similarly, the length of our dictionary
is just the lengthof the forward dictionary.
And the way that we iterate
over the keys of our dictionary
is justiterating over the
keys of the forward dictionary.
The mutating functions like __setitem__and __delitem__
do have to involve thebackward dictionary, though.
We'll go through it slowly, but just keep in mind
that the mathematicalinvariant of this class is that
the forward and backward dictionaries
represent inversemappings of each other.
They should define a mathematical
one-to-one correspondence.
A key mapsto a value from
the forward direction
if and only if the value maps
back to the key in the backwarddirection.
So let's take a
look at __setitem__.
Taking a look at the end here, what
we ultimatelydo is maintain that class invariant
that the forward and backward
are inverse maps of eachother.
In the forward map, we map key to value, and in
the backward map, we map value to key- simple as that.
All the rest of this is to handle the cases where
either the key or thevalue already existed in the dictionary.
This checks whether the value that we're trying
to set already has a key associated with it.
If it does, and it's a different key, then
we're trying to break the class invariant.
We're trying to create two different keys
that map to the same value - that's an error.
This would happen if I started with the dictionary
like `` and then tried to set ``.
That's perfectly fine
in a normaldictionary.
But this is supposed to be
an invertible dictionary.
So if I had `1`mapping to
`'A'` and `2` mapping to `'A'`,
then what would
the inverse of `'A'` be?
Thatwould be an error,
so we just raise an exception.
This next case is for if the key that we're
trying to set already existed in the dictionary.
For instance, say
that we had 1 mapping to A,
so inthe backward dictionary,
we have A mapping to 1.
We could set 1 mapping to B
and B mappingto 1. That's fine.
But that backward dictionary
would still have A mapping to 1in it.
So we need
to delete it first.
It's okay whether or not the values were
equal. We're just going to reset it right here anyway.
Then we get to __delitem__, which
isthankfully much simpler.
We're given the key, we look up the value,
and then delete it fromboth directions.
Not too much going on there.
And that's all five!
Becausewe defined these
five, we can now use
our `InvertibleDict` justlike
we would any other mutable mapping.
Now, the most fun/elegant part, in my
opinion - how do we access inverse elements?
You might be tempted to do
something like make aninverse_getitem function
that takes values and gives
you back keys, and you could do that.
Butyou would end
up rewriting a lot of code.
You need the inverse __getitem__, __setitem__,
__delitem__, __iter__, and __len__.__get__
But wait, those are all functions that are
provided by `Mapping`.
I'm just describing another mapping.
So what we do instead isprovide one extra
function to access the inverse.
We make a `.inv` property that just
swaps theforward and backward maps.
Forward and backward are already inverses of
each other, so I don'tneed to do any extra work.
I just create a new `InvertibleDict` whose
forward map is my backwardmap
and whose backward
map is my forward map.
Then, check it out -
we can use it justlike this.
We create an `InvertibleDict`.
We can print it or print its inverse.
Wecan check that 1 maps to A.
And we can check that
the inverse of A maps to 1.
Then we can assign the
inverse of D as 4.
And then check that 4 maps to D.
Thisworks because the function and its inverse
are sharing the same underlying dictionaries.
Modifying the function is modifying the inverse,
and modifying the inverse is modifyingthe function.
Because I defined a repr,
we can print these things out.
the repr only shows
you the forward dictionary.
So if we print the function, we see
``.
And if we print the inverse, we see
And then thesecond lines,
we can see that setting the inverse `'D'` as `4`
actually sets both of them.
Thiscan be extremely useful when you're
translating between two different representations
of a fixednumber of objects.
A way to tell if you might benefit from using
this kind of invertibledictionary is to ask yourself:
Do I have just two dictionaries that have
the same data mappingin opposite directions?
Like, if you had two dictionaries
`int` to `char` and `char` to`int`,
That's the kind of situation where you might have
data on either side and want to convertbetween them.
So feel free to use this idea!
Alright, I do have one more
practical piece of advice on thematter.
We saw an implementation that
was inheriting from `MutableMapping`.
And `MutableMapping` was
providing a bunch offunctionality.
It defines `pop`, `popitem`, `clear`, `update`,
all these things, andit defines them correctly.
But that doesn't mean that these
default implementationsare the most efficient.
For instance, look
at how it's doing `clear`.
It'sbasically got a
`while True` and tries to pop items.
It's popping items off one
at a time until it gets a `KeyError`.
Now, for a general `MutableMapping`, that is
sort of the most general thing that you can do,
that would be correct - pop
things off one at a time.
But our implementation is using two dictionaries,
which both themselves have `clear` methods.
We don't need to pop
things off one at a time.
So for efficiency sake, you may find
yourself re-implementing a lot of those functions
thatyou were supposed to
get for free as mix-ins.
From my own experience, I've definitely
foundthat to be the case,
especially for the more
complex interfaces like `MutableMapping`.
And after a few months or maybe a year,
I've re-implemented everything that was a mix-in.
At which point, I may even
no longer inherit from `MutableMapping`
and instead just use a typing
`Generic`, or not inherit from anything at all.
Just remember
that if you do this,
you willprobably want to make
your class register with `MutableMapping`
so that it will still betreated as
a `MutableMapping`, a mapping type.
And finally, for the more advanced
typing users, unfortunately,
I'm not going to talk about one of the bigger
benefits of using these interfaces.
It has to do with covariance
and contravarianceof type variables,
which, unfortunately, I just have
not set up the prerequisites totalk about.
But if your extra studios go ahead
and look those up in the typing library.
I'm sure there's plenty
for you to learn.
Thanks to my patrons
and donors forsupporting me.
If you really like my channel,
please consider becoming a patronor donor.
Don't forget to comment, subscribe.
Slap that like button an odd number
of times, and I'll see you in the next one.
Also, I have a secret giveaway
for anyone who stayed to the end.